who was Kelsey Bharath Kelsey was a kind
sweet girl who was spunky and playful
you know shy at first but was really
easy to get along with I'm just thankful
for the friendship that she gave me and
for being the person that she was
I mean I'm inspired by her and I'll just
I'll just take that and I know that she
that's what she would want she would
want us to focus on the good you've lost
one of your best friends but in the most
horrific way I guess what gets me by is
knowing that she'll never feel an ounce
of suffering ever again never ever again
will she feel an ounce of suffering and
I think that she would just want us to
remember her for all the great that she
was you know and and give her daughter a
good life you know in friendship circles
everyone has their role what was your
role in the group and what was Kelsey's
I was maybe the one that was a little
bit more outspoken and she was a little
bit more quiet she was the one with like
a lot of that spunk underneath
underneath that quietness but she just
kind of went along for the ride she was
real laid-back and it was just it was
easygoing it sounds like she was a
combination of softness and steel yes
kind of went tough yeah exactly
she was real tough